um so hello everybody my name is Safi um
you can find me as Captain Sofia on
Twitter and github and my website is
Sofia rocks which is an amazing
top-level domain although people think
I'm a bit full of myself for having it
I'm not trust me
so this talk or this tutorial slot is
gonna be a little bit interesting
because it's a 45 minute tutorial slaw
which is the shortest one of the day and
so in a lot of ways it's going to be
like a talk and like most talks it's
going to be very focused on the slides
and I've made the slides available to
you at this bitly link if you go to
bitly forward slash PDC Juby kernels you
will find the google slides for this
presentation you can download them read
for them all that fun stuff and with
that being said if you came here for the
poppin kernels talk you are in the right
place that I am the right person and
stay in this room please for a little
bit longer we're going to be talking
about a couple of things today and I
just want to give you a rundown of what
you're getting yourself into over the
next 45 minutes so we're gonna start off
by talking about what kernels are and
why they're important in the Jupiter
ecosystem and then once we've
established understanding of that we're
gonna talk about the Jupiter messaging
protocol which makes messaging possible
and is really the crux of these kernels
and once we've talked about that we're
gonna talk about how we can build our
own kernels by leveraging the Jupiter
messaging protocol and then at the end
I've prepared a quick exercise notebook
that goes through how you build your own
kernel arms that you can go through the
process yourself
practice a bit and then take what you
learned and like do something awesome
with it that's the goal of this so I'm
gonna start off by posing a really
simple question which is what is a
kernel and there's a variety of
definitions for what a kernel is
depending on the context of computing
that you're working in in this
particular case we're going to keep a
pretty
um textbook style definition of what a
kernel is we're gonna define a kernel as
a program that runs an INT respects user
code so in Jupiter kernels are in charge
of keeping things like the execution
state and you see this in that little
number on the side of your cells and
Jupiter that represents when you've most
recently run a cell or what order you've
run it in it keeps track of the output
that cells should be returning or
commands should be returning it tracks
the state of the kernel itself so is
this kernel alive is it dad has not been
responding for a while and the kernel
accepts processes and sends messages
essentially it's really a communicator
and more importantly a single kernel can
be connected to multiple front tons so I
can have my jupiter notebook and my
jupiter console connected to the same
kernel with the same context it's really
a kernel is a messenger it manages state
and manages program output and so what
happens when you like go on your machine
and you're like really excited to do
data science or research or whatever it
is that you do and you type in Jupiter
notebook on your terminal well what
happens is Jupiter is going to start a
kernel and create what's known as a
connection file and a connection file is
really just a simple JSON document that
contains some information about how a
front-end in this case your web-based
notebook can communicate with the kernel
and once that connection has been
established via the information found in
the connection file all that happens is
the front-end and the notebook or sorry
the front-end and the kernel communicate
with each other via JSON messages it's
just JSON back and forth pop and back
and forth requests responses it's like
one really long chat now you're probably
thinking the connection file seems to be
like the start of this process like it's
how front-end and kernel
like you know how there's like When
Harry Met Sally when frontend meant
Colonel is like made possible by the
connection file so what does a
connection file look like what kind of
information does it have that makes this
connection possible so it looks like
this Oh kind of scary
well we'll dive through it together so
you'll notice that one of the parameters
that's provided is an IP in several
different ports that compromise the
different sockets of your kernel and
we're gonna go through what those are
and what they're responsible for in a
little bit and you'll notice that you
have a key and signature scheme field
and those are designed to secure
communication between a kernel that you
started so that other users don't have
access to that kernel and have the
ability to execute code on it that you
might not want them to and that's pretty
much the crux of it so really what you
want to focus on is those multiple ports
so you've got the control port the shell
port the standard input port the HP port
and the i/o pub port and we're gonna
dive into those in just a second so I'm
gonna keep you on the edge of your seats
until like I have like a big reveal
where I go through it all all good so
the next thing that's kind of really
mysterious is how do you go about
writing a kernel because remember I
mentioned earlier that a kernel is a
program and you write programs using
programming languages and all that fancy
stuff so there's two ways to write a
kernel in a kernel for the JavaScript or
the Jupiter ecosystem the first way is
writing the kernel in Python itself so
one of the Jupiter libraries that's
included is called I pi kernel
I PI kernel exposes a base class called
kernel base that you can subclass that
provides you all of the functionality
that you need to override standard
kernel functions
this might seem great
like whoa I can write a kernel for any
language in Python like I don't have to
like learn are to build a kernel for our
because our syntax is gross because
somebody decided that their assignment
operator would be an arrow that was not
know in my job with some people it
doesn't jive with me so the only caveat
there is that if you want to write your
kernels in Python there has to be a
repple some sort of rebel console system
for the language that you want to write
the kernel in and you're going to
communicate with that rebel and send
messages to it
using P expect and P expect is a Python
library that's used to launch child
processes and communicate with them so
for example if I was trying to build a
Ruby kernel I would launch the IRB
process which is Ruby's interactive
console and send messages back and forth
to that and have it doing the actual
execution so that's how you write
kernels in Python and that's what we're
gonna be doing later on in our like
quick little exercise so you guys are
gonna get really comfortable and get
your hands dirty with that and then
there's another way to write kernels um
that's a bit more involved so we're not
going to be covering it in the later
half of the tutorial and that's if you
want to write the kernel in the native
language so let's say that you're
writing a kernel for Ruby again if
you're trying to a kernel in the native
language you'd be taking advantage of a
networking library and communicating
with all of the sockets at their
appropriate ports that were mentioned
earlier you would have to manage sending
messages back and forth yourself you
would have to do a lot of dirty work I
think that building kernels in the
native language is a great way to learn
that language because it helps you get
in touch with a lot of really advanced
concepts in the language like networking
or data structures so I've been
programming for a while and I'm at that
point where
like intro to go or intro to Julia books
are no longer appealing because they're
so simplistic and they cover a lot of
the basics this is a great exercise if
you're an existing programmer and you
want to gain knowledge in the new
programming language but you know take
the advanced route you can always have a
stab at building a kernel for Jupiter in
that language so that's a fun challenge
for you if you're ever bored and curious
on a Sunday night as many of us are I'm
sure and so with that we've kind of
covered what a kernel is which is
essentially a program that messages
through a front-end using port specified
in a connection file now I want to talk
about what kind of messaging happens
what kind of messages are exchanged
between the front-end and the kernel to
make all the cool stuff that a stupider
happen and do this protocol is known as
the Jupiter messaging protocol it's
really like a good name which you don't
find a lot in computer science you
usually find like not good names but so
when I find a good one I get really
excited about it and the Jupiter
messaging protocol like any messaging
protocol basically defines the
specification for how messages are going
to look when they are sent from the
front end to the kernel through those
ports and when they're sent from the
kernel to the front end through those
same ports so it's just a spec and it
looks something like this this is the
message structure of a traditional
Jupiter messaging protocol message
you're gonna start off it's a JSON
payload it contains a header it contains
a parent header which references data
from the previously called command it
contains some metadata so maybe perhaps
the time the message was send the user
it was sent by if you're building a
kernel in the metadata you would have
some kind of like kernel specific things
that you might want to keep track of and
it also contains the content of the
message which is itself a nother
dictionary or JSON payload
and so there's the basic structure and
there's different kinds of messages that
are sent in this basic structure and
what that means is that for a given
message that looks like this you're
gonna have different values in the
content key and the value of those
values is going to depend on which
socket it's set through so remember when
we looked back at that connection file
and there were those different ports so
had your standard in you had like a HP
port you had like a shell pour all of
that good stuff these ports are gonna
come in handy when we talk about the
different types of kernel sockets that
exist so I'm gonna list them all out
here and then we're gonna go through
them one by one talk about what they do
talk about how they're implemented a
little bit and then talk about how they
are useful to you as a jupiter user like
how they're manifested in your daily use
of the program so the first type of
socket is the shell socket you remember
we saw the shell port in our connection
file the second type of socket is the
i/o Publication socket which is not as
named is named much better than the
shell socket so you have a standard
input socket oh you have a control
socket and you have a heartbeat socket
so all of these if you recall the
connection file where referenced as
ports in the connection file so we have
a way to communicate with all of these
when our connection file is created when
we instantiate a Jupiter notebook
instance all right let's start off by
discussing the shell socket so the shell
socket is really responsible for
managing communication with all of the
front ends the room just got really
bright because of this like very bright
meme it's flooded with light on all your
faces so it's responsible with
communicating with all of the front ends
and it does this using a request reply
pattern so what happens is we've got a
front end and it sits there and
it wants something done so it's going to
package a message in that format that I
showed you earlier and it's going to
send it through that porch to the socket
the sockets going to the current through
the socket to the kernel the kernel is
going to parse that message try and
understand what the user is asking for
and what they want and send a response
back via a JSON payload that contains
its response so it looks something like
this so here's something really common
that happens whenever you use the
jupiter notebook tap complete if you
want to check if a particular statement
that the user has written is complete or
not that's something that the kernel is
responsible for the front-end can't do
that independently so what you do is you
might send a message that looks like
this
you've got your header which contains
some information about the session the
date that it was sent the version of the
messaging protocol you've got your
metadata and in your content you have
the code that you want to check if it's
complete in this case we've got an
incomplete print statement say send this
over through the socket port through the
shell port to the curl the kernel looks
at it says ok the user wants me to check
if this message is complete let me go
ahead and do that really quickly so it
does that and it sends back to you a
response the response looks pretty much
the same except you'll notice that the
content has changed instead now the
content says that the status of the
status is incomplete referencing that
incomplete print statement that you sent
earlier and this is really useful if
you're doing something on the front end
like say you want to have a bright red
color flash whenever somebody's got an
incomplete statement in their notebook
or like you want to play you want to
like rickroll them if they've got like
an incomplete print statement you could
use this specification to do that
so again the shell socket is based on
request and response and so you're
probably wondering what can this help us
do in our day to day Jupiter use in
addition to checking if a statement is
complete well there's a lot of other
ways that it's used so tap complete is
another way that you can use it if you
want to get information about the kernel
that you're connected to you know what's
the name of my kernel what language is
it in what version if you want to send
out a request to the kernel to execute a
chunk of code like so you've got a
complete print statement and you want to
tell the colonel all right take care of
this for me send me back the response
all of this is done by the shell socket
it does a lot of the heavy lifting for
those of you who might go on after this
and start to develop your own Jupiter
kernels the shell socket is probably one
of the more complex wants to build in my
opinion the neck socket that we're going
to discover talk about is the i/o
Publication socket you got a sneak peak
of my jiff there because my hands were a
bit quick but I like to think of the i/o
Publication socket as the announcer in
the family and the socket essentially
publishes data streams to standard
outputs and returns payloads that
contain information about HTML or images
that need to be rendered so for example
if you've ever had to render like a
matte plot lib graph or any kind of
image when you're using the Jupiter
notebook the i/o publication sockets
helping you out with that so give it a
thank you next time not but it doesn't
have feelings it's like not a human so
maybe don't so what else does it help us
do well it helps us do things like keep
track of the current Crowl state which
is good to know you want to know that
your kernel is alive and well it streams
outputs that are like Consequences of
execution like plots or renders and the
next target socket that we're going to
talk about is like really humble and
self-explanatory and timeless which
makes it great which is the standard
input socket and you're gonna really
going to need this when you have a
situation where the kernel is going
to want to request and put from the
front end so for example perhaps you
want to execute a Jupiter cell that
contains Python code that uses raw input
to ask for input from the user the
standard input socket is going to be
used in that case and then the second
socket or the fourth socket getting
ahead of myself there is the control
socket and the control socket is like
the muscle of the socket family it's the
big gun and it can basically do
everything that the shell socket can do
with one additional caveat which is that
it's a completely separate socket and it
can Trump things in the queue so for
example when you have like not that this
has ever happened to me but say like
you're playing around with so I can't
learn and you start training a model and
you realize one of your parameters is
off and you want to like quickly like
you know stop that cell interrupt the
kernel and restart all over again all of
that is handled by the control socket
because you want your interrupt the
kernel message to take priority over
that ongoing you know command where
you're running code that contains model
training or model fitting and then the
last socket is really simple to
understand any meek in its own way but
very critical to the kernel ecosystem
and it's the heartbeat socket and so
I've mentioned that all of the messages
that we've been sending have been JSON
messages so you're sending Python
dictionaries the heartbeat socket is
really special instead of sending JSON
it sends a simple byte string back and
forth between the front-end and the
kernel and as the name might suggest
it's used to keep track of the kernel to
make sure that it's still open and alive
so if you're using the notebook web app
you might notice on the side there's
that indicator that says you know kernel
running there's a green button your
kernels all well you like panic a little
when it's red
all that is being taken care of by the
information that's sent from the
heartbeat socket those are your five
sockets these all make the magic happen
um and they're all implemented on that
standard sending back and forth of JSON
messages in really an agreement on what
messages look like and how responses to
them should look like
it's like specs are good or something
Wow no one ever told me you're probably
wondering like what makes the actual
magic happen what are the socket things
that I keep mentioning and where are
these ports and how is that facilitated
at a lower level and the answer to that
is a lovely little library by the name
of zero and Q is definitely not the
topic or the concept of this talk but
it's a messaging library and it provides
a really excellent API for socket based
communication
raise your hand if you are not a data
scientist but to write software to
support data scientists okay nice raise
your hand if you've ever done low-level
programming yeah so the level network
programming is like a form of torture in
and of itself I think the CIA has
classified it as that and 0 and Q really
makes that easy it's got a simple API
it's got tons of bindings across
different programming languages so I
mentioned earlier you might want to
write a kernel in its native language
you would use these 0 mq bindings
available in that language to open up
communication to the front-end and send
your messages through that and a fun
fact the Python bindings for 0 mq are
actually maintained by a lot of the
jupiter developers so give them a thank
you and a cupcake next time you see them
for doing that and so really the main
point that I always try and like drive
to people during this talk is not the
low level
how the message looks like or how it
works because there's like documentation
for that even though nobody reads it but
it's really just a protocol it's an
agreement on how messages should be sent
and how responses should be sent and
that's a really robust thing you don't
have to limit yourself to thinking about
just building a kernel for a language um
if you've got a special kind of DSL or
querying language that you use your
company you could build a kernel for
that you don't have to limit yourself to
the standard um like I'm gonna build an
our kernel or I'm gonna build a Giulia
kernel you can get really creative
because all it is is a messaging
protocol it's like go crazy and disrupt
[ __ ] as always how I like to say it so
now you've got this knowledge you get
what a kernel is we have understanding
of the Jupiter messaging protocol we
know how to pass messages back and forth
and we know all about the different
sockets the next thing that we're gonna
try and go through is build a kernel and
I know this is a tall order because it
seems like a really intense thing to do
and this is the part of the talk that
I'm gonna try and make really
interactive and fun so what I'm gonna be
doing is going through a jupiter
notebook that i've created already and
explaining how you might go about
building a jupiter kernel using the
python subclassing technique I've
created a version of the notebook that
I'm going to go through that's fill in
the blank style so it like makes you
like run the gears in your brain a
little bit which is fun to do
occasionally it's located at this link
if you want to check it out I'm gonna
give everyone the chance to take a
picture or open it up on their machine
and I'm gonna go ahead and switch to
mirroring my display right now so I can
go through this notebook with you guys
so you guys seeing my display yes you
are
so I'm gonna go ahead and open up is
that good sighs that's not it's too
small so I'm gonna go ahead and open up
the existing notebook that I've written
for this and you can find it online um
this is basically what you have there
but it's filled out completed and what I
based this off is a Bosch colonel that
was developed by Jupiter developer named
Thomas and what I've done is kind of
broken up that code and gone through it
and we're just gonna go through each of
the steps that are shown in this code
and kind of like do a walk-through it'll
be super fun who's feeling tired it's
okay if you are
I understand it's late afternoon it's
like everyone's feeling dead
can you guys engage in an experiment
with me okay everyone stand up let's go
yes now you're gonna put your hands up
all the way to the top and try and reach
all the way up yes
come on try really hard both hands yes
and then you're gonna gently bring them
down slowly
try not to slap the person next to you
although that's okay
they won't sue and then you're just
gonna like shake your hips a little bit
and loosen it up yeah do a little dance
in your seat you know get it going
all right now I could sit down do you
feel like more energized now and ready
for the second half of the talk this is
gonna be a super quick walk through it
will be linked in my Twitter after this
talk is done the question was where can
I find this notebook so I'm gonna tweet
out the link once this talk is done so
be sure to follow me on Twitter for the
link and for like
funny jokes yes and also just come up to
me afterwards and I can show you the
slide again so alright we're sitting
here we've learned all this stuff from
Sophia about like Jupiter kernels and
like our brain is stuffed and full and
we want to start to build our own oh
we've got Python 3 install we've got
Jupiter installed already because we've
been using it in our day to day job or
just playing around with it and we want
to take it to the next level so we're
gonna open up our text editor vim Emacs
atom a stone tablet from the 21st 21st
century that's just an iPad that you're
about I said the wrong thing and then
the joke just saw itself so to start off
you're going to import the base kernel
class which is stored in the I pie
kernel module that kernel if you've ever
had to install a Jupiter kernel before
you like have to type in I PI kernel
into the command line to install it so
it's exposed as a shell command but also
as a module that you can use which
contains the kernel base class that's
kernel right there and once you've
imported that base class you can start
to use it for all the fun stuff so the
first thing we're gonna do is we're
going to create a bash kernel class
that's going to subclass the kernel that
wage is created can everyone see the
screen alright is that zoomed in well I
forgot should have asked that earlier I
was just so excited to make you guys
stretch and shake your hips and stuff
and then inside this bash kernel class
you're going to need to specify a couple
of different variables these include
variables that describe the language
that your kernel is in as well as the
language version as well as the
implementation of the kernel itself so
this is my bash kernel and it's the
first version I made last night at 11
p.m. because I definitely don't
procrastinate promise there's this fun
banner variable which when I first
discovered it I was like what
do you have to like look a lot in the
documentation to find it out the banner
is what is printed out when somebody
starts your kernel in console mode so if
they're not connecting to it via a
notebook front end they're connecting to
it via console front end the banner is
gonna be printed the first thing so if
you're like building something
internally inside your company you might
want to like print out you know license
information or warnings about use or all
that fun stuff
so the banner is a good thing to know I
keep a close eye as I go through these
things because in the link that I shared
with you previously the there's a lot of
fill in the blank so if you want to take
notes and like cheat to figure out what
you need to fill in the blanks with
that's fine too and then you're going to
need to add another parameter or
attribute to your new kernel class and
that's something called language info
language info I'm gonna ask a quick
audience question to the audience to see
how curious you guys are raise your hand
if you've looked at the raw JSON for
your notebook if you look you've opened
a notebook file in a text editor or vim
or something like that yeah and if you
scroll through it and you see this
language info key the language info key
contains the exact information that you
specify here in your kernel and this is
really useful for a couple of things
you'll notice here we've got the code
mirror mode key inside our language info
dictionary this is used by the front-end
to determine what kind of syntax
highlighting it should use so in this
case we're telling it to use shell based
syntax highlighting on the front end
which is like a good thing to have if
you want people to enjoy using your
kernel it also specifies things like the
file extension which links into when you
export a file from a Jupiter notebook
instance it'll add in that file
extension at the end that d'audace sh
this is a useful thing to know it might
be blank in the notebook that I shared
with you so this like is a good way to
cheat on your homework I'm such a great
teacher
so once we've created sort of these
basic attributes that need to be exposed
in our kernel we're going
jump in and instantiate the kernel
itself there's a couple of things going
on in our instantiation for the bash
kernel here and it sounds overwhelming
I'm gonna try and put it in a very
simple way to start off we're going to
call the initialization function in our
parent class the kernel class and this
is going to take care of instantiating
things like the execution count the
execution cow is that little number you
see on the side of all your Jupiter
cells that like changes as you run them
or like clears and all that and then
it's going to make a call to another
function that's called start bash and
this function instantiates
a connection via P expect to abash
repple and we store that connection in a
variable called bash wrapper you can do
this with other tools as well I
mentioned earlier if you want to build a
ruby kernel you might instantiate a
connection to a IRB or an interactive
Ruby session to start off just like back
and forth this is how we initialize our
kernel and then what's really great
about the sub classing technique is that
there's really only one function that
you have to fill in or code up in order
to get your kernel working and that's
the do execute function and the do
execute function has got a lot going on
but it's responsible for handling
believe it or not another thing in
computer science that's named well what
the kernel should do when it sent a
request to execute a piece of code and
it's a function that keeps takes in a
couple of parameters these parameters
include the code that it needs to
execute there's a parameter called
silent which describes whether or not it
should suppress output there's a another
parameter called store history which
defines whether or not it should update
the execution count there's an allow
standard input which says you know is
this execution request allowed to
request input from the front-end and you
can configure these to your liking based
on what kind of functionality you want
your kernel to have
and then really in the bulk of the do
execute function you're going to have a
lot of your logic so the first thing you
might think of is maybe you know I have
a sneaky user and they like requests to
execute an empty cell and you don't
really want to do anything if they
haven't sent you any code to execute so
you know you might check you know have
they sent me any code using this simple
if statement in Python and if so you're
going to return back a JSON payload
because remember all of this is JSON
um and that JSON payload is going to
specify that it was an okay status like
nothing broke no errors occurred Trump
was not elected president the IceCaps
did not completely melt it was mostly
fine it's going to maintain the
execution count and it's going to send
back an empty payload and an empty user
expression stick so this is kind of like
the you asked me to do nothing I did
nothing here's like just everything's
okay and you're sending that back to the
front end now let's say that they do
have a valid command that they want you
to interpret well one thing that you're
going to want to do is send that command
over to the bash wrapper that we created
earlier and request that that command to
be run and you're gonna store the result
of that command in this output variable
and you want to keep track of a couple
of different things since this is a bash
kernel let's say that like they decided
to like do catch on a million line long
file and they instantly regretted it and
they're like pressing ctrl C to get out
of the command you want to be able to
detect that keyboard interrupt and
appropriately send an interrupt signal
to the bash to the bash ripple and then
change the variable appropriately now
similarly imagine like they truly
panicked like they accidentally ran that
shell script that they like built when
they were 10 and just getting into
programming that like overloads your
disk with null data and just tears
everything and they're like panicking
and pressing ctrl D which sends in and
of
I'll signal and you just want to restart
the entire kernel and all of that you
can do that here
this final accept so restart the bash
session and Riaan Stan she ate the
wrapper that you have around bash so
this kind of takes care of executing a
valid command or code and then all of
the other things the user might send
unexpectedly now we mentioned earlier
that you can send back outputs using the
i/o pub socket which is super handy and
you'll notice that it's referenced here
in the sender response function that
we're making a call to sue essentially
here you're saying if the user hasn't
requested that output needs to be
suppressed we're gonna go ahead and send
back a simple text of whatever was cat
it out so you know if it's like they're
silly like ASCII art or what-have-you
it's going to be sent back via the i/o
pub socket and if they haven't actually
executed anything if they've requested
that the kernel be interrupted earlier
we had sent the interrupt kernel and
we've kind of set a boolean in addition
to doing that we want to make sure that
the front end knows that we recognized
and accepted their request to interrupt
the current session and to do that we're
going to send back a simple payload and
change the status so that the front-end
is aware so notice it's pretty much
standard syntax or standard payload for
everything you're just kind of changing
what message you're sending and another
thing that you might want to check for
is if something has aired out which is
terrible for the user but also something
they should know about so one way to do
that is to request that the shell
execute a simple command and see if it
can do this okay like if it's fine to
try and execute this echo command and no
exceptions are raised then we know that
it doesn't need to exit abruptly and we
don't have to send back an error to the
user once again the air
is just a JSON message that you send
back to the user and then finally if
everything is okay you're basically
going to send a simple payload that says
you know the status is okay here's the
execution count a payload and the
results of user expressions and this is
what do you execute looks like for our
bash wrapper and I broke it down earlier
and as you go through the notebook
yourself and your spare time you'll be
able to see it much better it seems like
a lot right it's like a really long
function like this is bad programming
you should break it up into separate
functions but this takes care of all of
the edge cases and potential and
potential uses for that kernel so you
take care of when you're not getting a
message you take care of when you're
requesting it be interrupted you take
care of errors all of that good stuff so
when you're building kernels for other
languages this is where a meat of the a
bunch of the work happens and you can
use a similar template if you'd like as
you start to build your own kernels just
kind of follow along with what I have
but instead of bash wrapper and using
like an echo command to test for errors
you might use the language specific
functionality that you're using so
that's our do execute function but
Jupiter and all of the other notebooks
do so much more than just execute code
cells so you've got like lots of cool
functionality that I talked about
earlier you've got tab complete you can
check if something's complete like all
sorts of cool stuff the kernel base
class only requires that you override do
you execute like you don't have to worry
about anything else but if you want it
to be like super fancy you can write a
do complete function that handles tap
completion out which I would do but then
that would just take too long and also I
did this at midnight last night so yeah
definitely not a procrastinator but this
is really kind of the most basic
simplest kernel that you can create
it specifies its implementation and the
language it needs and specifies the kind
of back end that's supporting it and it
specifies how it executes code and once
you've got this done um what you go on
and do is install the kernel and this is
usually done by specifying what's known
as a kernel spec which is a file that
explains how you would launch the kernel
so what commands you would run it
outlines what the name of the kernel is
so in this case it's like my bash kernel
and this is like the magic that connects
what you just wrote to the way that I
python or Jupiter new name branding
everybody got it gotta stay on brand or
Jupiter launches kernels and so all of
these things are connected together so
you've got a front-end you've got a
messaging protocol that manages how
messages are sent back and forth and
you've got the kernel itself which could
be either written as a Python wrapper or
in the native language which is like
super fun to do does everyone feel
comfortable and understand that or feel
like they can go back and read through
this notebook and kind of get a grasp of
it did I cheat did I enlighten you today
so I'm gonna jump back to my
presentation really quickly
technical difficulties potentially No so
once again if you want to go through and
fill out the empty notebook for this
lesson it's available at this link just
go check it out download it play around
with it once again I'm captain Sofia on
Twitter and github if you'd like to see
my open-source work or like what I do if
you have questions but you're too
nervous to ask in a public venue feel
free to email me at Sofia at Sofia dot
rocks and I will try and respond soon
like once I'm done with the playlist of
cat videos I have to get through I'll
get to the emails I have to go through
fast that was my talk I hope everybody
enjoyed it I will be around today
and the rest of the conference to answer
any of your questions and any of your
feedback and I'm gonna unplug and give
it to the next speaker
thank you everybody